let's bring in Leo routings former
Syracuse player I believe drafted by the
76ers and now works with the Raptors on
their telecast their broadcast as the
Raptors and Golden State coming up
tonight Leo thanks for joining us on
short notice let me ask you the question
that I posed to our audience and that is
more important title if the Raptors won
or if the Maple Leafs won a Stanley Cup
final for all of Canada well you know
what I think in today's dance today's
environment Toronto is a multicultural
very diverse City the country itself
reflects that and honestly the way the
way the game is impacted Canada and the
diversity within the country I think
that NBA championship would be
unbelievable and would put the country
on a complete pivot as far as the
direction of sport I really do
how would you describe the style of the
Raptors if somebody had not seen them
play this year a lock down defensive
team it plays extremely smart at the
offensive end these guys I mean III
think that's where people underestimate
their coming into this series and then
this is the best defensive team the
Golden State Warriors have seen by far I
also talked about this at the start of
the NBA Finals I said two NBA fans hey
you know what you may wake up and go boy
the Raptors are pretty good or the
Raptors are gonna win this title it
feels like everybody is just focused on
the Golden State portion of this program
and that is if they win okay dynasty and
Kevin Durant leaves if they lose that
ends the dynasty what's that mean for
them going forward what's it mean for
Kevin Durant and then now we're getting
to the point where people are actually
writing columns saying what the Raptors
are a really good team and man they've
been the better team in the finals how
did you take this when you felt like
everything was kind of leaning heavily
towards Golden State coverage well I
thought that going into the series the
Raptors matched up extremely well I mean
think about they've beaten the goals
they're worse 506 times this season
and I felt the Raptors were the better
team coming in and it what's amazing Dan
when you think about the experts talking
about the Raptors this season they had
they at 58 wins second best record in
the NBA to the Milwaukee Bucks at 60 and
here's the catch there was no effort in
finishing first finishing at the top of
this or top of that the whole season was
about load management for Kawhi Leonard
getting him ready for further season the
trades getting new guys in the mix Nick
nurse experimenting with a lot of
different things and you know Kawhi
Leonard said the best it's 82 practices
to get ready for the postseason and when
you when you have that approach and you
have the second best record in the NBA
that's pretty impressive and and then
throughout the playoffs arguably you
know not arguably the best defense of
the playoffs and then you wonder how you
know a lot of the experts are just over
looking to Steve and now acting
surprised that the Raptors are where
they are so you know I really felt based
on matchups and first of all the Raptors
you know it certainly could be the team
to win this series you think Durant's
playing tonight no I don't think we're
gonna see him in a series uh as the
people I've talked to and just based on
the nature of his injury and what he's
able to do right now I just don't see it
feels like unintentionally they've done
even a disservice though Leo because it
feels like we keep waiting for him to
come back and then you start to say
what's the big deal
I mean it's a calf injury why aren't you
coming back when I thought all along
this is a serious injury and it's not a
week or two weeks it's more than that
longer than that and I did it just feels
like Durant may be getting more blame
than he deserves
yeah I mean I think the longer something
like this goes you it's almost like what
happened with Kauai last year where
people are saying he doesn't want to
play and that's the last thing you could
say about Kawhi Leonard he wanted to
play he was frustrated he couldn't play
thought you know he might have you know
things going completely soft and as far
as the South goes and you know Kevin
Durant he wants to plays a pro he's a
lot of the elite players in this league
so now you get people that start
questioning does he really want it and
that's when it gets
ugly so yeah I agree with you I I don't
I don't understand that if he indeed
ends up not playing why is this kind of
continues in this process hey does
anybody think about the possibility of
Kauai leaving Toronto right now
it's a possibility right there's no
question about that but IIIi think the
Raptors have made a great case for him
staying there and yeah I think there's
there's there's a few factors that are
you know obviously the success of this
team this season and if they win a
championship that's a it's a huge a huge
bonus I think the fact that the Raptors
put his health as a primary concern all
season long Alex McKechnie director of
sports science did an unbelievable job
of getting Kawhi Leonard where he is so
that's that's a big point and in light
of the fact that he did have this
serious injury and pretty much missed
the entire last season rappers can pay
him 50 million dollars more than anybody
else and if you had an engineer like
that that has to be a consideration and
the last thing is troubles a heck of a
city so I think the rapper's are
definitely in the mix more likely to
stay or leave if the Raptors win I think
you're more likely to stay especially
when you look at the other pieces you
have management and their commitment to
winning this may not be a one-shot deal
if you have if you do stay leo good
stuff thank you for joining us we
appreciate it and have fun tonight
thanks a lot dad appreciate it that's
Leo Robbins former Syracuse player I
believe drafted by your 76ers McLovin he
was a vague memories of him as a kid I
know he was not like a great success in
them no he wasn't a great shooter and
his son great shooter young poly he was
a good player for the QS right before
the sherman Douglas days right before
right around Pearl Ward before Pearl and
Sherman Douglas took over mm-hmm for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]